brit hume is fox news senior political
analyst he joins us tonight thanks so
much for coming on what's so fr i mean i
think all of us who are you know over
the age of 13 acknowledge that human
beings make terrible mistakes often
what's so infuriating almost to the
point of becoming intolerable is their
unwillingness to say i'm sorry we
screwed up here's where we went wrong
just admit
publicly and with sincerity
what the rest of us are seeing why won't
they do that
it's been a refusal to do that since
this debacle first began to unfold i
think that has characterized this
president and his administration's
response to it yes there were heroic
things done by the military and i think
as well by diplomats working on this to
try to get as many people out as they
could but they were responding to an
emergency of their own creation right
there isn't a military strategist that i
know of her planner who does not think
that this whole
evacuation was seriously underplanned
undermanned and poorly thought out and
rushed
so
there clearly there's that and that is
biden's doing biden wanted out he wanted
out in a hurry he wanted out by august
31st and he got he got the military out
of there which seemed to be his chief
exec chief objective suppose he had come
out today and said look
it was the right decision to get out but
we didn't execute it well and i'm
responsible for that these were my
decisions i regret them deeply i
apologize for them i deeply most of all
regret the loss of life that this may
occur and i and i promise you that if we
have to send troops back in there to get
our people out we will and the taliban
ought to know that but but i the bottom
line is i'm responsible i'm sorry we're
going to do better my guess is and you
don't see this in modern politics but my
guess is the public would be much more
forgiving of him than they're likely to
be now
i i i mean this i truly mean this i
would be grateful to hear that from him
or any other president
it just seems like it's
counterproductive
for them to tell us that what we're
seeing on television is not a disaster
that everything is great it's a massive
success and you sort of wonder like how
long can they keep saying that what is
the plan here do you have any idea
well i think in political terms uh uh
tucker what i suspect is that this is an
effort to rally the faithful to give the
faithful something to say and you heard
in the words of matthew dowd there whose
silliness is almost beyond comprehension
that that uh you know this was a success
beyond what anybody imagined biden was
saying that as well i you see pieces of
that
in social media where people are trying
to stick up for them
but the verdict i think by and large
across the news media
has been
almost unanimous condemnation of this as
a failure and it's pretty well set now i
think in the minds of journalists who
are covering washington covering the
pentagon covering the state department
covering the white house that this has
been a calamity
that's not going to be easy to overturn
and i think the public having seen weeks
of this
has probably reached the same judgment
whether they'll be willing to forgive
biden or let this thing pass into their
the recesses of their memory remains to
be seen i have my doubts i do too i
really do britt hume thanks so much for
that
bet hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else